what is happening there reject nation we
are back at it with umbrella academy
season three episode four been getting
better by the episode aaron thanks for
rejoining me here thanks for having me
ladies and gentlemen if you could leave
a like i know you can there's no ifs
here do
don't be a coward subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction from umbrella
academy is up isn't that right aaron
dm straight
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page along with a bunch of other
shows that we cover as well thanks to
the prep bush helping us edit this down
aaron apparently deactivated all the
social media so he's just here out of
the kindness of his heart
let's get to it not here for clout no
the fun for them and this guy is always
about like oh i want to act and all that
but i want nothing to do with getting a
following i gotta detox man need it for
myself
my health
mental
i'll come back eventually
yes time one time i storm on instagram
hey they had this song in season two as
well do they really i remember huh
now we're going back to season two
i remember dealing with the copyright
issues
we'll take us back
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
damn replaced her already oh my god
[Music]
oh man she could have gotten laid harlan
[ __ ] it up for mom
[Music]
now then you can blow up
[Music]
come on bro
where's that rabbit energy
[Music]
oh no i know where this is going
damn always had to stay on the run for
him
poor guy damn
[Music]
whoa
super saiyan form
wow
oh so we must be going to victor for
answers on what happened to him got it
uh
that makes sense that makes it oh
yeah okay
oh damn he so they are dead yes oh my
god totally
maybe they might be alive
no he burned their faces off oh my god
[Laughter]
what did you do did victor go full carry
again
are you all right
[Music]
oh no
sloane don't turn on him
you got a live one loser where you going
you never been here before
hey
go help luther what about you i can
handle it okay okay
oh it's slow not run outside
that was the first time that the first
time in a title without the umbrella
possibly just let me talk to her
okay
please
trust me
she's gonna talk
ow
oh jesus i get what you're going through
man yeah this sucks for my ears right
now so we're watching with headphones
[Laughter]
ever since that day
at the lake
[Music]
we're connected
i can feel you people
like you
it does
oh
i'm
not special like you hey you are dude
you found off just vibes
alone the hell
is it
i don't know
where
[Music]
so you just like mess with people's
you just give them many seizures like
that do you just make people nosebleed
is that a thing she can do now i think
if you fight it but she didn't know but
was she fighting she didn't actually
know she was resisting answering
easy going
yo that's [ __ ] up you can't gaslight
yourself into happiness girl why not
daily affirmations
[Laughter]
daily practices come on girl
meditate no
i think she's just cutting her hair dude
[Laughter]
don't do oh it looks good you cut your
hair
yeah i'm you now
i can't deal with this
right this second
we can talk later okay no
not okay later please
i heard a rumor that you were getting on
my nerves
[Laughter]
you walked us into a slaughter you were
both right there with me this is as much
your faults as mine how
your number one remember yeah but i'm a
different kind of number the shitty kind
yes
definitely
you don't know how to lead
you don't have what it takes
oh shut up his ass
isn't he actually number two
yeah yeah because he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
would have never left gone
you know what a real problem is
you
you're a [ __ ] number two thing
[Laughter]
someone's projecting even christopher
agrees with me
[Music]
seems like christopher should be the
number one yeah he's the brightest of
all of them i'm ben
i've always
i'm not talking like this
[Laughter]
he means they're dead
such a shame
he's partially relieved
what happened those [ __ ] from the
umbrella academy after marcus
disappeared ben let us on a mission to
take them down and it would have worked
if it wasn't for those damn kids you
asked him about the mother [ __ ] yeah
what do you say that he didn't kill them
oh you believe him well i don't know
it's hard to say the sparrows have got
them all doped up like a like a me
do you recall this
blinding orb of light
now we're done
why does no one ever believe
about the most important thing
that's like the trope of the show
everyone always doubts class the
timeline is collapsing
this is
the end
[Music]
no you got dusted be immediately
reminded to the operations bunker
the founder
what founder i don't know
the founder of all this um
you attacked us i tried to warn you at
the last second you almost took us out
yeah but we didn't your stupid family's
fine and half of mine is dead
yeah but it would be the complete
reverse situation
and then it would be okay
if you're playing me right now
you win if this is for real
we have to trust each other because
we're not our
families she's hot
yeah you know he once gave me six months
laundry duties it doesn't really seem
that bad well it is when you know what
your brothers do into their socks
ew
that is bad yikes it's typically
associated with an argumentative
aggressive irritable mood exactly yeah
anti-social yeah we're seeking behavior
and impulsivity ding dong who's at the
door me
put it back
okay you caught me i thought you were
supposed to be the fun uncle
i know me too can i just keep one thing
all right you can keep the panties
i can't let you go
i don't want to let you go either but
jamie and alfonso they deserve a proper
burial no i mean
i can't let you leave oh no no
your sister called you victor is that
what i should call you
i'd like that
you know your mom's uh
fox
[Laughter]
she was the first person to truly see me
your mama changed me boy
she never stopped thinking about you and
she never gave up hope
that you come back to us one day dang
she's had a bunch of rebounds
i needed you
we thought you'd be safer away from me
but i wish i'd stayed
i should have stayed
well victor could be like the dad that
he never had growing up that was true
can be the dad to this 80 year old man
he was just trying to protect me this
only works if i can convince my family
he isn't a part of your team so is he
with you or not harlan saved our asses
he can stay here as long as he wants you
know what luther
he can take your bet since you're
sleeping with the enemy
hey you were banging lila and now you
got a kid the audacious
i was out i was done yet here i am swept
back into the chaos
it's helpful because you love it
my bad
i hate flatulence
[Laughter]
you know i don't know why people keep
saying that i don't actually like what
that means there's another him there's
another hymn somewhere in there really
that's because he has the symptoms
remember oh yes
you know you're way more fun these days
is she she got more off but
just a little edgy they call me dr fuego
no one calls you that they should though
that [ __ ] sounds better
i feel like i've never seen these two
bonds
i've never seen a scene with them you
spend enough time in the city you get to
know a few things
people in there
hate people like us
even in this timeline the races oh i
thought it was my superheroes
did not get it
[Laughter]
let's go [ __ ] up some races yeah
what if they get there and they're like
hey you're you look like that woman from
the 60s you changed us for the better
the flag means completely are you the
daughter of her granddaughter
i everyone would get her a drink
[Laughter]
round's on me
[Laughter]
it's simple
bring us the man who killed our siblings
and this will all be over might as well
just use the old man and
kill you ben right
we're screwed
jesus you're sweating like a dodgy
shrimp on ice what's wrong
you must have a another version of
himself there i'm guessing for my own
personal guesses that works from anyone
else's genius
who would have thunked that
[Music]
oh my god you caused the chaos man you
started the fire
oh there he is
there's the five here you are thinking
you didn't like any of this
you think you put it together
after a week ago experience you
literally just went through this
[Laughter]
founder
looks like tim b oh my god five was the
founder what a cinnamon twist it's me
i don't have paradox psychosis
i could feel it outside but in here it's
nothing
never worked too bright
were we no buddy
you must be here because of a
cuckoo split
[Music]
cuckoo blitz how do we fix it
you don't if you created all of this
then you must have created a solution
[Music]
oh my
is god you have coming
so tell me
how you stop it
whatever you do
don't save the world what
don't save the world
i like how there's like a it kind of
looks like a broken god
with the beard and the loin cloth
this is so cool i adopted them instead
of you dad i'm not your father young man
i don't know what's happening
[Laughter]
chop chop stan gotta go see a man about
a bum
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] oh my god yo
oh my god kloss is going to be a ghost
class is going to be part of the dead oh
my god you little [ __ ]
a little freaking [ __ ] oh man i liked
you kid he just pissed me off man damn
all right i make him like him all of a
sudden oh wow
he just killed klaus
what a random way to go right
was that a harpoon gun
oh what the hell
i just got a theory
reserve it
victor's mother
why is he getting upset
kind of plays into my theory
you need to stay in your room
what's wrong
why would he do that vibes he was going
off the vibes
he was searching for him
they roll off the hospital now
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] oh god damn
no no
oh my god
oh that's exactly what i was going to
say
that looks very
bad yeah
oh god
[Music]
oh is that from the first episode yeah
yeah oh these are not as good nipple
chills guys that's a hell of a twist
yeah that's a hell of a twist you did an
umbrella academy and then being the 60s
is what caused it in the first place
[Music]
all right
keep your mouth shut
you killed our mothers
you caused all of this
technically you caused all of this
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's what i was going to say this
is the umbrella cafe
yeah that that was that was great that
was really really great i mean exciting
just hop in the top we're gonna watch
the next episode uh right away in real
time so just
talk about it damn
um
he picked up on that theory that theory
yeah that only took me a while
it was like two seconds before they
revealed it i was like oh dude that's
where we're going with this yeah man i'm
like him looking at it and i was like
you know it makes sense because he was
he's been around this whole time and he
said he goes off of the vibrations of it
that's what i picked up on at least but
then him causing it all at once
i was like oh that's interesting i
wonder why that happened why did that
happen so he doesn't have to be in the
same vicinity no he's just he's just
like stupid powerful yeah
more powerful than vania really at one
point you mean victor victor you're
[Laughter]
i am the first one uh
yeah no i think
it was trippy um watching
that go down because i was like okay
so he is the the catalyst for everything
going down which is caused by them
because they had to save the universe in
the first place from vanya in season one
so it's all
it's all connected
i mean even beyond that
five is the one who
is the
the founder yeah the founder yeah of all
this yeah that paradox all about yeah so
it's like they're responsible for
everything
that is gnarly that's a crazy twist
because yeah the the whole thing i i
like um five and lila's uh chemistry and
i like their their scenes together but i
kept one ringling okay come on we're
just going we're gonna get somewhere
yeah we're gonna
speed this up a little bit come on i
don't want to see what's happening here
and then when they got to that reveal it
is a really cool reveal to uncover that
five is indeed
the founder of the
of uh what's up damn what's it called
forget the name of it the tva yeah yeah
essentially right the bureau the time
bureau yeah but it's saying don't save
the world and it's such a it's such an
antithesis set up for what you do with
this character who's all about your five
is the character you depend on to really
help save the world in both of these
seasons and now being told to do the
opposite of that
uh it's like there's this inevitability
uh to it and i am liking i am liking how
they they pair up lila and five
ah
and i do like the sloane girl the
sparrows this girl's not getting any
better to me
by far still the worst part
they're really really unaffecting i'm
hoping they get back something happens
to make them more uh interesting um
but damn that thing with ashtray
that's something
stanley uh killing uh um
seemingly killing klaus well it seems
like there was something that was
surprising seemingly he shot him right
through the center nobody has a ghost
powers i don't know he
can do something bring himself i mean i
i think it's just the inevitability of
the fact that klaus is always his
abilities to communicate with the dead
and now he's part of the dead
yeah i think i'm curious to see where
that goes and how
how his power
affects himself or like how is he going
to communicate with his siblings if he
is truly dead
it is like a weird
like there's this almost weird slice of
life approach to this season sometimes
you know what i mean
well it's just like
sometimes [ __ ] happens
um
stanley you're gonna clean up the hotel
klaus you just deal with him because no
one wants to babysit you
they're bonding klaus is like i have an
opportunity at a new life i am bonding
with this kid they walk into a random
room hey
this um
what are those called the stuffed
animals almost what is it called again
the
i don't know what the hell are those
called again oh my god mounts uh you
know what i'm talking about yeah the
animals the dead animals yeah
and then picks up a harpoon
kills them
it's like
it's like a random like
sometimes that random [ __ ] just happens
in life like it like
it's like so weird plotting like i would
have never ever predicted from the last
episode that klaus is going to hang out
with stanley you know
it's just a thing that just happened but
funny enough actually for the time we
have them i actually personally enjoyed
their dynamic definitely more than him
and diego's dynamic i don't know
something about like the child like
klaus with like a literal child that
just really appealed to me well it
started to make sense too of like
pairing them up like and in a lot of
ways you probably is the one who could
relate with klaus because klaus is such
a troublemaker and and and was always
acting out and also like you see that
stanley has a an understanding of
of psychology but kind of uses it to
manipulate situations instead of using
it to become a better person
[Laughter]
and i i did i did appreciate their
their bond together and i like this
bookend of
seeing
like what really happened in that moment
because i'm like okay he acted out he
thrashed the room but we didn't didn't
really seem like that was that
consequential so
it's a good mislead i think in terms of
your setup because in the beginning
you're like all right you're watching
what happened with um
sorry guys
at the time of filming this i'm working
off of two hours of sleep
so
um what's your cece doing good what cece
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] with [ __ ] the
beginning of it
you start off with [ __ ] and you're
seeing okay here's what happened with
them
and when she ultimately died
and then you watch him act down that's
kind of like the birth of that power
uh that harlan has and that's what it
seems like it's all about and then to do
that full reveal at the end the book
ended with that
there is something ominous and it
creates a conundrum because
you feel bad for him you sympathize for
him he never asked for any of this like
he already had a tough enough life
before he had powers yeah and out of the
m and it really does seem like he's just
cursed
and he obviously didn't intend to kill
anyone right no he's just a victim of
circumstance
but a dangerous victim circumstance
right and now the sparrow academy is
going after him
now it's like how does
victor handle this situation himself now
yeah does victor tell the rest of the
team like other does he protect
does protect harlan because he feels
responsible for everything very yeah
very interesting sort of dynamics where
we're playing with here and like how the
the story is unfolding it's like the
tensions are raising and somehow now
we're finally getting to the meat of
what's going on in the story i know each
one has kind of been
the end of the world but somehow they
can continue to raise the stakes in a
more believable
zany way and it's it just progressively
gets more enjoyable this season took a
little bit to get started with that but
as we i think the
the rate from
not enjoying it to enjoying it is like
exponentially like steeper than previous
seasons
true true
i mean harlan stepping in just like was
a kind of a game changer i think for the
momentum of this season true no i feel
that as well you know killing off the
sparrow two memos or the the sparrow
academy and
the the the aggressive conflict i i
i i was like sometimes alice when
allison did give her speech um to diego
in the car i'm like all right i get it
yeah i get why your feet yeah
i was like yeah you can't get on my
nerves but then i'm like i know i know
you gotta make a good point
yeah she didn't actually bother me as
much in this episode because i feel like
we're seeing a different note from her
granted
sure
weirdly enough i have a similar issue
with uh with obi-wan but i think the
fact that they
they did something that was
illogical and but brought it to a place
that was um
that felt like it was fresh i think that
really uh resonated and i really enjoyed
watching that yeah
yeah i can't i don't go into spoilers
for like how i related to obi-wan but
like
yeah i i felt that i thought it was uh
it was good it was good stuff
what are you doing
hello hey i want to keep it close to
your mouth close to my mouth like that
yeah you are talking that pervert voice
yeah baby
i'm dead
i'm number one i'm like a weird anime
carrot yeah he's totally looking back
but not cool or intimidating
i need to be the leader
prove my worth there's no rest to my
voice
to these faces
you've got an attitude problem
my clothes are too tight
so frustrating i do like the chemistry a
lot with sloan and and luther i do i do
like their chemistry like i do think
there's not much writing happening with
her either it's very thin very thin yeah
all everything with the sparrow academy
incredibly thin
uh you think they would give it more of
a [ __ ] for them it's still it still
bothers me um
um but
the actress i feel really elevates that
role 100
it helps that she's hot too but she's
really good at it
she's really genuinely she's really
working with actually no like her their
chemistry is really solid and their she
does bring more of a depth to the
performance that makes her more engaging
to watch like i'm making jokes like yeah
she is a good looking person but
um if she was just good looking i would
be standing here going like she's just
good looking but it is kind of a boring
character
but she makes the character more
interesting like i really enjoyed that
moment i thought her performance was
good when she was dealing with the rumor
situation or when she is
i believe
her and luther's chemistry and i believe
the moment when she is going up to them
being like i want to stop this if you
want to rumor me you can't just rumor me
like whatever it takes to end this i
will
yeah and i'm hoping she comes out of
this alive yeah i was gonna say like
them being in the same place is
paradoxical alone so how do they
how do they reconcile past this season
how do they
evolve their relationship path this
season because i'm really rooting for
them i'm like oh you guys are like the
one good thing that's like
positive out of this whole experience of
the timeline situation of this season so
i'm like i want to see their progression
i want to see luther be happy with
someone other than a sister
yeah
i think i think that it took a while for
this season to kind of get like a
a good pulse about it because it's like
season two is a really
like an immediate pulse you know solid
season we're trapped in the 60s we need
to fix it when you get back to the
timeline because we got to prevent an
apocalypse from happening like just
immediate you know yeah and then
character exploration along the way and
here i'm like i don't know what
direction we're going
what's the path here and now uh it's
starting even right now i'm still like a
little bit
like i don't know where this is gonna go
i don't know i don't know what the goal
is here right now better than to fix
this space time you know and the goal is
to fix the space-time continuum problem
but everyone's yet to be involved in
that space-time continuum problem it's
like just lila and and five know about
it but that's what we're gonna watch
next episode right away
but guys
thank you for being here this is a good
episode had a great time
aaron youbomb.com
i also had a great time and it's uh
it's beautiful it's a beautiful show it
is a beautiful show man
i don't have socials to plug so i can't
i can't
yeah
all right all right
bye
[Music]